we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
straightforward and simple question that
came in on our voicemail line overnight
nelson from a midwest
i just want to know who the hell are we
voting for against trump hoping he can
clear that up for the next three weeks
but i can't clear that up i can't clear
that up and this is in general i've said
we shouldn't talk about 2020 until we're
past 2018 we're almost past the 2018
elections i don't know who the hell were
voting for in 2020 i don't know i just
really don't understand the question who
the hell are we voting for against trump
like politicians against Trump's agenda
maybe that could relate to the 2018
midterm oh I understood it as who are we
going to vote for in 2020 to get Trump
out of the White House Oh like what
remedy shion's then I guess yeah and I
have no idea who we're going to vote for
this is a real problem and I've been for
the last year I've been making my notes
with my thoughts about what the
Democratic Party should be doing for
2020 and I will start to discuss that
very soon because we're almost past the
midterms so stay tuned for that we've
got a great bonus show I'm out of time
but it's a good one I hope to talk to
you on the bonus show